so it's been 48 years since you were
originated shafts it's been 19 years to
play them what made now the right time
to kind of bring it back and what took
so long
River once answer for me was a telephone
call oh we're doing another one would
you like to be a part of it I said you
know it's salmon involved in it yes of
course Sam is about it I'm all on board
well I just got free I was booked from
the last one I have I took me that long
to get back to class I had 19 years ago
I did chapter I'd have to play okay fine
I'm moving this year it is time yawns
worked out that way locked up in that
marble deal man brother snap to the wall
no you can't go work for anybody else I
would have been with something you like
we're having me working on a script that
whole time or is it something it was
something funny I was I was producers
house John Davis yeah John does his
movies he carbon Network yeah so just
used to be the son of shaft and it was
really call center shaft so what was
what sort of your impression did you
kind of know shaft you get to go back
and do some study I mean I assume you're
seeing this is a bit of both it was a
little bit about a new shaft I knew that
universe I knew the the feel of it
you know the mythology of this character
but I had to go refill from familiarize
myself with the tone and just
perspective a little bit so that when
you know when I was walking into this I
don't want to just walk in and
completely just be blind to who I would
be working with you know what they would
be bringing to the film I just didn't
want to be that guy so I did a little
bit of homework before before I got
there and I'm glad I did so you come in
late act all tough and Tim said no wait
no you're playing different role in our
serious you know even the first scene
that I shot was just more so me asking
questions directly about the death of my
best friends so like to me it was a
little more serious and then even in
that moment Tim was saying it's just a
different tongue than what I was doing
and you know from there I was able to
lighten it up and then Sam comes and
comes in right afterwards and then we
were able to just play it was just
playing around and in finding the film
early early on so that we can build from
there mister after you know the original
movie is obviously a classic it's a it
had some humorous moments but is very
serious and it was for the times what do
you think of the kind of more comedic
take on this one we're just locked a lot
more laughs and actually I think to take
it to the next level it had to have a
new point of view if you will and the
humor takes it to that level it's fine
to be serious and knock them down drag
them out and whatnot but that they had
you need to elevate it if you want you
want to take it to a new level and this
film does that and you get to love three
generations of experience through this
film
well that's pressure I don't ask what
the women bring to this movie because it
isn't very different to have chefs
ex-wife your your childhood friend
having the women and this was just such
a very different bit they've been women
but not like to this level I think it's
great that you see what our relationship
was prior to him being separated from me
and that whenever these two people are
in each other's presence you can feel
the heat you can feel the electricity
you know there's and a magnetism between
these two people but there's always that
something that gets in the way which is
mostly me you know to see him develop a
relationship with you know a specific
young woman that takes it out of the
realm okay he was a sex machine for all
the chicks I had a magnetism of some
sort we give him that when he's in the
club and you see wow you know there's
something about this young man
you know the chapt ism of what it is but
he's chosen in this generation so
generationally he defines who he is
even though we keep trying to define him
he keeps telling us no that's not way